[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
closing arguments in the federal trial
of r kelly what evidence has been shown
to this jury for them to be able to find
him guilty trial attorney bernarda
villalona gives us a window inside the
courtroom and a political heavyweight
takes the stand in the federal trial of
elizabeth holmes what this testimony
could mean for the former billionaire's
case plus the search continues for brian
laundry we asked fame forensic
pathologist dr michael baden what to
expect from the autopsy of gabby petito
as her death is ruled a crime they think
right now that they know that it's a
homicide and later scott peterson back
in the courtroom what will it take for
the convicted wife killer to receive a
new trial long crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
and welcome to law on prime daily i'm
simon choudry in for brian buckmeyer
along with terry austin now we begin in
the federal trial of r kelly as closing
arguments are underway in what some
would say is a bizarre comment defense
attorneys compared the singer to martin
luther king jr saying the government
must be held accountable
ahead of this the prosecution wrapped
their closings and after nearly six
hours that stretched across two days in
court earlier this week testimony in
kelly's trial finally concluded after
nearly five weeks with 45 witnesses
testified against him including 11
accusers and former employees
r kelly faces charges for multiple sex
crimes including sex trafficking and
racketeering the r b singer opted not to
take the stand in his own defense
well the government painted the singer
as a predator wrapping their closing
arguments with two simple words
convict him
but the defense quoted mlk's i've been
to the mountaintop speech adding kelly
did not have to recruit women
well trial attorney bernarda villalona
was at the courthouse today and she
joins us now to explain what she heard
the government in this case the
prosecution has concluded their closing
arguments closing arguments that lasted
about six hours how they broke down this
case for this jury to be able to
deliberate on these charges you heard of
the video evidence you heard of the
corroboration in terms of text messages
in terms of phone records in terms of
there is certain video and letters that
were found in the storage facility for r
kelly aside from that the prosecutor
also went into great detail about the
medical records and how r kelly had
genital herpes and had sex with at least
two of the jane does who contracted this
herpes from r kelly in addition to that
you heard about the three jane jones
that were all under age that r kelly
in sexual contact with them despite
their age you have sexual exploitation
you have forced labor you have bribery
you have all these types of racketeering
acts and the prosecutor in this case was
able to break it down i'm bernardo
theolona from the law and crime child
network
all right thank you for that report
we're joined now by co-host terry austin
and law professor kirk burkhalter now
kirk let's start with you and let's
start right away with the defense's
comparison of r kelly to martin luther
king jr and on top of that they compared
girls calling him daddy to former vice
president mike pence calling his wife
mother now this is an unconventional
closing argument to say the least
unconventional to say the least and i
would say more of an act of desperation
the problem with that type of closing
argument is that you risk alienating and
offending the jury and especially in a
case that involves uh sex a sex crime
sexual assault some form of sexual abuse
and underage minors and so forth juries
are not very tolerant about that we also
heard this uh
this argument that he did not need to um
to get women so to speak in this manner
and that's one of the oldest most
offensive arguments that sexual
predators tend to make so it's certainly
an act of desperation by comparing uh
himself to martin luther king um it's
about as close you can come to a
blasphemy when talking about a non-deity
and i think they risk very much
alienating the jury and it will be seen
for what it is just an act of
desperation and a hail mary pass
interesting yeah those are some risky
words now terry this has been a long
trial with a total of 50 witnesses
including five for the defense do you
think the defense has established
reasonable doubt
no i don't i mean there might be one
juror who thinks that but in addition to
doing a closing that was a hail mary as
kirk said i think that they failed to
put on defense witnesses who would help
kelly's case each of them got on the
stand stating that they never saw any
abuse by kelly when in fact they just
were not in the room and as far as the
women were concerned saying that they
were doing it on their own and that they
were willing that too is something that
sexual offenders often claim so i don't
think that there's any doubt here and i
think that at the end of the day the
verdict will come back against kelly
all right well we have some other top
celebrity news as well this time we're
talking about pop star britney spears
she files to have her father removed
from her conservatorship immediately
i've worked my whole life
i don't owe these people anything
in a filing this wednesday sphere's
lawyers petitioned a los angeles court
to replace father jamie spears with a
temporary conservator brittany her
lawyers argue that jamie spears should
be removed right away due to the
singer's recent engagement and plans to
negotiate a prenuptial agreement now all
this comes weeks after jamie spears
suggested the 13-year long
conservatorship
should come to an end both sides are set
to meet back in court on september 29th
now that's just one day after the
netflix documentary britney versus
spears chronicling the ups and downs of
her conservatorship well is set to be
released
all right turning now to arizona the
jury is officially seated for the man
accused of killing a mennonite school
teacher mark gooch is charged with the
first degree murder of sasha krauss a
27-year-old mennonite school teacher who
disappeared from her community in
january of 2020. her remains were found
over a month later in arizona an autopsy
revealed she died of blunt force trauma
and a gunshot wound to the head
now cell phone records put gooch in the
area at the suspected time of the crime
previous text messages from the
defendant that showed disdain towards
the mennonite community were also
uncovered well a crime lab reported that
the bullet taken from kraus's skull was
fired from a gun that gooch had in his
possession
jury selection concluded on wednesday
now the court was dark on thursday but
opening arguments are set to begin on
friday
well still ahead on law and crime daily
the ongoing search for brian laundry the
person of interest in the death of gabby
petito
but first a former defense secretary
takes the stand against elizabeth holmes
in her federal wire fraud trial
more on what he had to say that's next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live one
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
and welcome back to law and crime daily
we turn now to the west coast as the
federal trial of former billionaire
elizabeth holmes sees a political
heavyweight testify for hours on
wednesday former defense secretary james
mattis took the stand for nearly four
hours detailing his investments in the
company to the tune of eighty-five
thousand dollars mattis served on
theranos's board from 2013 to 2016
on wednesday testifying he was
interested in the company's products to
be used in military application
holmes faces 12 counts of fraud for her
time with the now defunct theradose the
stanford dropout claimed the company
would revolutionize blood testing but
later investigations found many problems
with those tests now if convicted holmes
faces up to 20 years in prison she has
pleaded not guilty
so bringing back co-host terry austin
and law professor kirk burkhalter terry
so far we've heard from former employees
and now a prominent board member what
comes next i think the prosecution is
doing a great show right now they put on
the former employees the first one they
put on actually was the former
controller who said that investors lost
billions and millions of dollars but i
think they're going to do the employees
they will do the investors they will do
the board members and i also think they
are going to show patients who were
injured as far as the blood tests were
concerned or injured in the sense that
they didn't get the proper results so i
think it's overall going to be very
effective demonstrating that investors
lost money but we really had real people
behind those who were injured and that
would be the patience
the emotional part of this well kirk you
know let's talk about this the
prosecution argues holmes knowingly
duped people out of thousands of dollars
but the defense argues she always
intended to revolutionize the blood
testing world but failed at her goal so
how could an argument like this hold up
well you know that's always the the our
counter argument to intent is oh an
accident or i didn't know now if you
look at the witness that went on today
james mattis a very credible witness
four star general uh former defense
secretary
and if he thought that there was some
impropriety and he felt and alluded to
the fact that he felt that he was
somehow being
the board was being taken that goes a
long way to dispel this theory that
while i intended to do the right thing
but this just so happened this was an
accident
at best it was negligence so it's it's
the only argument that one can make
because the result is the result the
product did not turn out as it was uh
intended to be so the prosecution has a
very strong case just like terry
mentioned however
she has to rebut this evidence that's
right all right intentions here is going
to definitely be obviously under the
spotlight now let's stay on the west
coast again in california where an army
veteran is now charged with kidnapping
rape and attempted rape of three women
after more than a year-long spree
authorities say robert yuka's kidnapped
these women off a running trail in
orange county between january of 2020
and august of this year in early
september yucas was identified as a
suspect in a san diego crime while the
dna evidence in that case helped
pinpoint him as a suspect in the orange
county attacks the veteran has been
charged with eight felony counts
relating to the attacks and faces a
maximum of 39 years to life plus six
years if convicted on all charges
coming up on law and crime daily new
updates for scott peterson yeah i
remember that name well he's the man
convicted of murdering his pregnant wife
what he faces before the possibility of
a new trial plus the search is on for
brian laundry what charges gabby
petito's fiance could face if he's found
[Music]
welcome back many questions still
unanswered in the disappearance of gabby
petitto another day of searches come up
empty as authorities look to find her
missing fiance brian laundry the search
continued thursday near the florida
reserve where laundry told his parents
he was going for a hike that was last
tuesday meantime witnesses who saw the
pair just days before potato disappeared
have now come forward a jackson hole
restaurant confirms the couple ate there
and have reported the information to the
fbi another couple who say they were
eating at the restaurant at the same
time remember brian laundry fighting
with a manager a waitress and a hostess
they say laundry was acting aggressive
and petito even apologized on his behalf
board-certified forensic pathologist dr
dr michael baden says witness
information and body cam video from
before her death is taken into
consideration when determining manner of
death
this shows how important social media
has become whatever has happened
prior to the death
that is
can be viewed such as the scene or
whatever statements have been made to
other people
is part of the autopsy and that helps
determine the manner of death
let's bring back a law professor kirk
burkhalter and co-host terry austin
terry if brian laundry is located what
possible charges could he face as of now
as of right now he could be facing
charges of fleeing the scene obstruction
of justice i mean obviously if they find
more information as far as the body is
concerned and as far as what actually
happened to gabby he could face charges
such as murder or manslaughter and i
think that if in fact they know it was a
murder
it could be tied back to him and i find
it interesting also that his parents
could face charges of obstruction of
justice because they did not assist with
finding where brian is we still don't
know where he is and kirk an autopsy
confirmed gabby petito's manner of death
is homicide but so far we don't know the
cause of death in your legal opinion
when can we expect to have more answers
well this is really important because
the definition of homicide is when one
causes the death of another but that in
and of itself doesn't mean that one is
liable for a criminal penalty so we
could find it out soon however
given that the
uh the boyfriend is still missing it's a
possibility that they do not want to
release that information because on it
on the uh hopefully they find him
they'll be able to interrogate him and
question him and so forth and you don't
want to give him too much information
that being said in this day and age we
could find that out pretty much any day
i would suspect that they certainly have
an idea
of how she died as opposed to just
simply really in a homicide
of course we'll be continuing to follow
this story but we're going to turn now
to more top legal news and 25 years
after her disappearance a judge rules
there is sufficient evidence to take the
murder of kristen smart to trial
a father-son duo paul and ruben flores
are charged in connection to the 1996
disappearance and murder of smart a cal
poly tech student smart was last seen
leaving a party with paul flores who is
now charged with her murder his father
reuben is charged with accessory
allegedly helping hide her body after
the fact although smart body has never
been found she was declared legally dead
in 2002. the pair have an arraignment
scheduled for october
and when we come back a new trial for
scott peterson our legal experts break
down the likelihood that the convicted
wife killer could be retried
[Music]
and welcome back an update now in a case
we have been following for years a judge
rules convicted wife killer scott
peterson will be resentenced to life
imprisonment later this fall this as
peterson's defense team inches closer to
the promise of a new trial
peterson was convicted of the 2002 death
of his wife lacey and their unborn son
connor in 2005 he was given the death
penalty but the sentence was later
reduced to life without parole
after the california supreme court cited
significant errors in the jury selection
it's on those grounds of juror
misconduct that peterson's defense team
say the court owes him a new trial juror
number seven later revealed to be
rachelle nice well she's accused of
failing to disclose domestic abuse in
her past peterson's defense argue nice
purposely tried to convict him because
of her past issues well court documents
show peterson's defense says nice will
plead the fifth amendment at next year's
evidentiary hearing unless granted
immunity from the prosecution on
wednesday a judge ruled peterson will be
re-sentenced to life in prison before
it's decided whether peterson will be
granted another trial all right let's
bring back terry and kirk kirk it's been
almost 20 years since scott peterson's
murder convictions what is the
likelihood he could receive a new trial
based on juror misconduct
well there are two sides this argument
one is the fundamental right to trial by
jury of your peers an impartial jury and
then the other competing argument is
that this impacted the trial that
somehow his trial was prejudiced and i
think that's the mountain that he has
declined given the weight of the
evidence everything that was presented
the outcome would have been different
had you not had this
jury misconduct so a lot of it is going
to hinge on the testimony of the uh
juror herself and what other evidence
they put forth not going to be so easy
for him to get a new trial
and terri break down exactly what this
jury misconduct issue is
well what the allegation is is that she
lied twice she was asked during voir
dear the questioning during jury
selection whether or not she was
involved in a legal proceeding she said
no well in fact she did ask for a
restraining order against her
boyfriend's ex-girlfriend that's a legal
proceeding she was also asked was she a
victim of a crime and she said no and
her explanation publicly for that was
well i don't consider myself a victim we
know now that she is claiming i'm not
going to get on the stand without
immunity we know the prosecution is
considering not giving her immunity
she's taking the fifth so the question
really is why can't she say what she
said in public on the stand
and kirk when you hear what terry's
explaining
do you think that's going to have an
effect on on what's going to be the
outcome because how can you prove that
she intentionally did this
she is not on trial so this cannot be a
trial about the juror scott peterson was
the party that was on trial and this is
about him and the reason why i bring
that up is there's only but so much
evidence that can be brought to light
again you know to determine whether she
intentionally lied it's really going to
be her word and whether she is believed
so it's going to be very difficult to
prove this and it depends on how
the veracity of her testimony whether
she is to be believed
and terry could this issue make future
jurors think twice how they answer
questions during jury selection
absolutely she could be held in contempt
and future jurors i think are going to
be worried about the fact that they may
have to pay a fine or even serve jail
time so i think whatever happens to
rochelle neece is going to have an
impact all right well obviously we will
be continuing to follow this i want to
thank both of you for joining us and
joining us here on law and crime thank
you for watching we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you